-You guys, Mother's Day
is coming up
and we wanted
to do something special
in honor of that, so,
we teamed up with Samsung
to celebrate five Supermoms
this week.
So we asked people to nominate
an epic mom in their life,
an amazing person who's gone
above and beyond this past year,
whether it's juggling jobs
or volunteering
or working on the front lines,
or anything else,
all while being a mom,
which is just a hard job
in itself.
We set up video interviews
with the moms.
We told them it was
for NBC's Instagram.
But what we didn't tell them is
that I was going to call them
-Ooh.
-on my new Samsung Galaxy S21
Ultra 5G phone
and surprise them with something
to make their Mother's Day
a little brighter, yeah.
Our first mom is Ashley Tuvalu
from Mesa, Arizona.
She was nominated
by her mother, Cara.
Check it out.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
♪ Supermom Surprise ♪
-Hi.
My name is Cara
and my daughter Ashley
is a Supermom.
She is so patient.
She's got the three little boys
all under five,
which is a handful.
At the beginning
of the pandemic,
Ashley, unfortunately,
was laid off from her job
and picked up another job,
working online from home.
They had been saving
for a house.
Had to put that on hold as well,
so we're all under one roof.
She is so in tune
with each of them
and each of their
individual needs
and keeping them safe, keeping
them happy, making them smart,
and putting good people back
in the world.
[ Chime ]
-Ashley?
Ashley?
-Yes.
-Are you -- Oh.
I'm sorry. Let me turn
my video camera on.
I'm sorry.
-OMG, that's Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Ashley, hi.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's Jimmy Fallon.
-Aah!
-We wanted to thank you
for being a Supermom, and also,
our friends at Samsung wanted
to thank you as well,
so we'd like to give you
a Samsung Galaxy package.
-Aah!
-I mean, this is everything.
You've got the watch.
You get the tablet.
-What?!
-You got the ear buds.
-All of that.
-Thank you for being
such a Supermom.
-Thanks, Jimmy!
Jimmy said my name.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, Ashley,
we have one more thing
that Samsung would like
to give you as well.
We'd like to give you
a check for $25,000.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Holy schnikeys!
-Holy schnikeys. [ Laughs ]
-You're on your way
to the house.
-[ Muffled ] Aaaaah!
-Oh, thank you!
-Your mom loves you
and we all love you.
Happy early Mother's Day.
-We love you, Jimmy!
-Thank you.
-Holy cow!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Come on!
-Amazing.
-That's great.
-Thank you to Ashley and Cara,
Samsung,
and all the Supermoms
out there.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.